Speaker 1: Let's now go to someone very different
than Chris Christie, and I'm talking about
Ron DeSantis.
Ron DeSantis put forth a plan yesterday on
Fox News.
So insane, so ridiculous and so deranged that
even Fox News host Martha MACCALLUM is visibly
skeptical and obviously doesn't buy it.
DeSantis was asked whether he wants to eliminate
any agencies, and he mentioned not only three
entire agencies, departments, commerce, energy
and Education, but he said he would eliminate
the IRS, which is so ridiculous.
But then the thing he says after that is almost
worse.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Are you in favor of eliminating
any agencies?
I know conservatives in the past have talked
about closing the Department of Education.
Would you do that?
Speaker 3: So we would do education, we would
do commerce, we do energy, and we would do
IRS.
And so if Congress will work with me on doing
that, we'll be able to eliminate the size
and scope of government, but also going to
do more things.
Be prepared if Congress won't go that far.
I'm going to use those agencies to push back
against woke ideology and against the leftism
that we see creeping in to all institutions
of American life.
So, for example, with Department of Education,
we reverse all the transgender sports stuff.
Women's sports should be protected.
We reverse policies trying to inject the curriculum
into our schools.
That will all be gone.
We will make sure we have an accreditation
system for higher ed, which is not trying
to foment more things like DII and CRT.
So we'll be prepared to do both.
Either way, it'll be a win for conservatives.
Speaker 1: Imagine for a second if a Democratic
presidential candidate said, I will be using
the IRS, the Department of Commerce, the Department
of Education, and the Department of Energy
to destroy conservatism.
Imagine for a second if a Democratic president
ever said something like that, they would
be calling for their head.
They would be saying lock him or her up.
Rick Wilson tweeted, I'll either eliminate
these agencies or use them to destroy my political
enemies.
Set every authoritarian in the history of
ever.
This is outrageous.
This is a dangerous extremist.
And by the way, give me a break, dude.
This is in the style of the Trump promises.
Anyone with any common sense knows it will
never happen.
He's not going to get rid certainly he's not
going to get rid of the IRS.
And I don't think if he was president, he
would get rid of the Department of Education
or the Department of Commerce or the Department
of Energy, which was the other one.
This is sort of like Mexico is going to build
pay to build our wall across the entire U.S.
Mexico border.
And I will solve the U.
At the Israeli-Palestinian conflict in my
first term.
We all know you're not doing any of that.
And after the fact, some people defend it
by saying, well, it was aspirational.
That's what he wanted to do.
Don't we want to hold our presidential candidates
in terms of the promises they make, at least
to some degree, to things that are remotely
possible?
So this reminds me of the classic moment where
Rick Perry, during his failed bid for the
Republican presidential nomination, also wanted
to remove a bunch of departments but forgot
which ones.
This is a classic, and I will tell you.
Speaker 3: It is three agencies of government
when I get there that are gone.
Is it commerce, Education and the.
What's the third one there?
Let's see.
Oh five.
Okay.
So Commerce, Education and the EPA.
EPA.
Unidentified: There you go.
No.
Seriously.
Is EPA what you were talking about?
No, sir.
We were talking about the.
Speaker 3: Agencies of government.
The EPA needs to be rebuilt.
Speaker 1: I don't know.
Remove them all.
Speaker 3: But you can't name the third one.
The third agency of government.
I would.
I would do away with the education.
Unidentified: The commerce.
Commerce.
Speaker 3: And let's see.
I can't.
Speaker 1: The third.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Listen, they're not getting rid of any of
these things, but they are extraordinarily
dangerous people.
And the fact that DeSantis is willing to say,
I'll get rid of the IRS, what we, of course,
need to do, if you actually want to take seriously
the idea of people who are not paying their
fair share and you actually need to you need
to scale up the IRS, need to give the IRS
the resources to actually conduct audits.
And we know that the multiplier effect, the
return on IRS audit agents to target extraordinarily
high income individuals is an extremely profitable
thing.
And as I've said before, if you hire an irate
IRS agent for 70 grand and they're mostly
auditing people making 30 grand, even if those
people underpaid their taxes by ten or 15%,
you're not going to recover very much money.
But we know that the very rich, underpaid,
I don't mean underpaid from a political or
moral standpoint.
I just mean they're not paying what the law
currently says they should pay based on the
tax code.
It's not legal loopholes.
They're just they're just putting in the wrong
information.
They're not paying what they should pay.
Under current law.
It's extremely profitable from the standpoint
of what you pay the IRS agents versus what
you end up recovering and people who didn't
pay what they're supposed to pay.
That's the direction we should go.
Not getting rid of the IRS.
But again, it's another one of these virtue
signals.
IRS is now bad.
It's political, it's, you know, armed agents,
blah, blah, blah.
Ron DeSantis, even if he becomes president,
is not getting rid of the IRS.
Think of your most personal emails.
If you're using a free email provider, you
should know that they're scanning every email
you send and receive even after you delete
it.
They're usually using the data to build a
picture of your life to show you ads, which
many find creepy.
Our sponsors start mail, never scans or tracks
your emails.
Privacy is what comes first.
And unlike other email services, when you
delete an email and start mail, it is gone
forever.
It also protects your data by blocking tracking
pixels in emails which companies and hackers
can use to track you.
You can create unlimited email aliases to
protect your identity and cut down on spam.
You can encrypt every email you send even
if the recipient isn't using encryption.
Start mail gives you 20 gigs of storage that's
more than you get on Gmail and it only takes
a few clicks to migrate all of your emails
and contacts over to start mail.
Go to start Malcolm slash Pacman to get 50%
off your first year.
That's only about two bucks a month.
The link is down below.